elle a hurlé elle a fait une crise de
nerfs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je dois faire un petit peu courte
derrière ça s'est mal passé parce que
vous savez qu'elle devait pas danser
avec Billy Crawford et elle a exigé donc
du coup c'était Catherine Patchett qui
devait et qui du coup elle a dansé avec
quelqu'un qui a perdu David Douillet
donc du coup maintenant c'est la star
des elle s'entend plus avec les autres
il y a une sale ambiance et vous savez
commencer quand tout d'un coup bah on
est plus aimé voilà c'est un peu la star
et du coup elle a décidé de quitter le
programme après elle commence un petit
peu à arriver sur des productions TF1
sur des séries oui je pense qu'elle va
se diriger dans la comédie moi c'est M6
qu'il a approché qui aimerait bien la
voir soit dans le jury la France a
incroyable talent soit pour présenter
une émission de flux sur la danse qui
devrait arriver bientôt
il faut qu'elle reste dans la danse elle
est magnifique elle danse comme tu as
jamais vu personne
une vidéo d'elle est devenue virale aux
Etats-Unis elle se trouvait dans une
épicerie aux États-Unis déjà l'ours un
client s'est mis à filmer en pleine
crise elle l'a agressé une cliente elle
lui a lancé des insultes racistes le
gérant lui a demandé ça sa carte
d'identité parce que c'est nécessaire
elle l'avait pas elle a sorti son
téléphone en mettant regarde mon nombre
de followers connard connard je suis
hyper connu c'est parti en bagarre parce
que d'acheter de l'alcool donc voilà
c'était beaucoup elle avait pas de carte
d'identité ensuite de ça et je voulais
faire courte le mec a fini par dire elle
est folle elle va payer elle a donné sa
carte et la carte a été refusée
[Musique]
elle a traité des gens de la terre
racistes elle a hurlé elle a fait une
crise de nerfs elle est surtout et elle
a essayé ses cartes bancaire et sa carte
bancaire était bloquée ça arrive d'avoir
une carte bancaire
tout le temps à tout point de vue et
être connu et continue de faire d'autres
télé à quel moment le public dit pas
c'était là et moi par contre c'est drôle
je suis beaucoup embrouillé avec elle je
vous dis pas les nombres de commentaires
que j'ai eu c'est comment tu as fait
Laurent pour tenir elle est horrible des
trucs horribles sur elle mais tu as
envie de dire qu'est-ce que tu veux
répondre aux gens à ça ben je sais pas
parce que parce que le public continue
d'avoir encore envie de la voir de voir
son excès qu'elle vient de faire un
pompe sur un plateau
elle fait le truc c'est comme à l'époque
on est dans le cirque on allait regarder
voilà la femme à trois têtes
et maintenant
non non mais voilà c'est une fille qui a
un parcours qui est très difficile mais
qui est très touchante qui s'en est
sorti et c'est vrai que quand quelqu'un
va un petit peu mal si on pouvait du
temps de la main plutôt que d'insulter
mais moi aussi
selon un voyant américain voilà les gens
qui vont disparaître en 2023 je vous le
dis Charles III Bruce Willis vous savez
qu'il est très malade et que ça va mal
Bill Gates beaucoup de risques John
Travolta non ah non pas John Travolta
salut sinon Jack Nicholson 90 ans
Michael J Fox
il est très malade
Kathleen Jenner Demi Lovato Ozzy Osborn
et alors pour vous dire la vérité parce
que il en met une couche il dit voilà
les gens qui vont mourir et je préviens
que j'avais déjà vu il avait l'année
d'avant il avait annoncé l'arrestation
de Bill Cosby et Dandre routes donc si
vous voulez il y a un petit moment où tu
te dis tiens il a peut-être bon alors
Céline Dion et le prince Charles de
malade malheureusement et le prince
Charles problème de santé fin d'année
2023 intervention chirurgicale et pour
Céline Dion pas de retour à la scène
d'une [ __ ] ton billet
[Musique]
on verra Kylian Mbappé papa non oui
2023 mais c'est génial mais c'est qui la
maman mais je suis perdu mais il a une
copine
Florent Pagny oh mon petit Flora alors
nous savons qu'il se base il se bat bien
et sera avec nous encore
je suis fan de se mettre alors Cyril
Hanouna enfin l'amour au grand jour
grosse décision
[Applaudissements]
me voilà ah mais du coup faut que ce
soit une séquence télé alors
oui
[Applaudissements]
vous avez 18 ans j'ai 19 ans 19 ans
gamine vous arrivez dans la Star Ac vous
êtes un petit peu différent des autres
parce que très sportive tout ça vous
chantez très bien vous avez fait des
duos avec enfin c'est magique vous
arrivez très loin je crois demi-finale à
peu près entre mi-finale en demi-finale
voilà et puis là ensuite derrière c'est
la tournée vous faites des énigmes des
Zénith d'hézinides vous dites un jour
dans un reportages c'est incroyable j'ai
fait la vie à l'envers parce que j'ai
commencé dans des Zéniths et puis
ensuite j'ai fini dans les salles où il
y avait 40 personnes parce que la suite
on la connaît vous faites des albums et
puis la vie c'est pas toujours facile
les albums marchent un peu moins c'est
ça la musique est très difficile et
avant d'avoir un projet qui fonctionne
c'est parfois faut être élu faut avoir
une chance et plus on avance plus on se
dit on regarde derrière on se dit j'ai
quand même vécu un truc de dingue au
moment de la star je crois voilà jamais
je crois que dépression derrière quand
tout d'un coup on va en 40 000 disques
et ça s'arrête ou pas tu peux pas tu ne
peux pas ne pas avoir de coup de blues
quand
tu étais dans une euphorie ou tu vis des
moments incroyables tous les jours mais
quand tu l'as pu et quand tu l'as plus
évidemment que tu as un coup de blues là
c'est humain c'est naturel c'est normal
et la seule chose qui fait que tu restes
sur terre c'est ton éducation ta famille
tes valeurs et puis de bosser et puis
retravailler
tu travailles et puis c'est tout